- Чи стане біткоїн золотом тисячоліття?
- Біткоїн падає до тримісячного мінімуму.
- Біткоїн - неймовірно брудний бізнес.
Це одна з найбільш суперечливих цифрових технологій сучасності.
Як усе почалося?
- Біткоїн - нічого не варте штучне золото.
І що відбувається тепер? За п’ять хвилин, ви дізнаєтесь усе, що вам потрібно знати!
00:30
Як з'явився (титр)
біткоїн?
Його історія пов’язана з іменем Сатосі Накамото,
який винайшов біткоїн у 2007 році.
Однак ніхто не знає, хто такий Сатосі Накамото.
Експерти стверджують, що Накамото насправді псевдонім
і, можливо, цілої групи людей. Є й чимало інших припущень щодо імен
імовірних творців біткоїна, але жодних доказів.
Тож авторство залишається загадкою.
Домен "bitcoin.org" був зареєстрований 18 серпня 2008 року.
Менш ніж через пів року була створена і мережа біткоїнів.
Чи знали ви, що перша реальна транзакція
з використанням біткоїнів відбулася в 2010 році?
Програміст Лазло Ханеш запропонував заплатити 10 000 біткоїнів
за дві великі піци вартістю близько 30 доларів на той час.
Якби він зберіг ті біткоїни, то міг би заробити в якийсь момент
цілих 100 мільйонів доларів…
Принаймні він увійшов в історію.
То що взагалі таке біткоїн?
Це вид грошей, який є цілковито віртуальним.
Це як онлайн-версія готівки. Ви можете використовувати біткоїни
для купівлі продуктів та послуг.
Він виробляється у цифровому процесі, який називається
майнінг - про це трохи згодом.
Кожен біткоїн - це фактично комп'ютерний файл, який зберігається
у "цифровому гаманці'' - застосунку на смартфоні чи комп'ютері.
Люди можуть надсилати біткоїни або частину одного вам,
а ви можете надсилати їх іншим.
Кожна окрема транзакція реєструється у загальнодоступному списку,
який називається блокчейн.
Це дозволяє простежити
історію біткоїнів, щоб люди не витрачали монети, якими не володіють,
і не могли робити копії або скасовувати транзакції.
Поки ще не багато магазинів приймають біткоїни,
а деякі країни взагалі заборонили їх.
Однак деякі компанії починають долучатися до обігу криптовалюти,
вплив якої дедалі зростає. У жовтні минулого року сервіс онлайн-платежів PayPal
оголосив, що дозволить своїм клієнтам купувати та продавати біткоїни.
З моменту свого створення біткоїн зазнав значних злетів і падінь.
Лише у 2020 році він зріс на понад 400%.
З іншого боку, вартість біткоїна вперше за три місяці
опустилася нижче 35 тисяч доларів після того,
як Китай наклав нові обмеження на криптовалюти.
Той, хто спричиняв як злети, так і падіння для біткоїна -
ніхто інший як Ілон Маск.
Він неодноразово демонстрував свою підтримку онлайн-валют
і спричиняв значні зміни в їхній вартості. Приміром, у лютому цього року,
коли його компанія Tesla оголосила, що почне приймати біткоїни для сплати за авто.
Але потім у травні Маск шокував власників біткоїнів у всьому світі,
оголосивши, що Tesla призупинила продажі автомобілів з використанням криптовалюти.
Це призвело до різкого зниження ринкової вартості біткоїнів - більш ніж на 10%.
Причина, чому Маск і "Тесла" відмовилися від транзакцій з біткоїнами -
те, що нині найбільше критикують щодо криптовалюти.
Процес створення біткоїнів, відомий як майнінг,
потребує величезних обчислювальних потужностей.
Простіше кажучи: видобуток біткоїнів - це процес створення нових біткоїнів
за допомогою надпотужних комп’ютерів, які у конкуренції одне з одним
вирішують складні математичні головоломки.
Це означає, що для цього потрібно багато центрів обробки даних,
які використовують багато електроенергії.
Ось чому багато експертів кажуть, що це надзвичайно неефективний спосіб
проведення транзакцій. Дослідження показали, що понад 75 відсотків
видобутку біткоїнів відбувається у Китаї, а дві третини електроенергії Китаю
видобувається спалюванням вугілля. Це означає, що електроенергія,
необхідна для створення біткоїнів, здебільшого походить від одного
з найбільш забруднюючих джерел енергії.
Згідно зі звітом Банку Америки, за останні два роки
історичний підйом біткоїнів призвів до збільшення викидів
на понад 40 мільйонів тонн. Це стільки, як коли б на дорогах
додалося майже 9 мільйонів авто.
Якщо це не переконує, зважте на інше: видобуток біткоїнів
виробляє більше СО2, ніж вся Греція разом узята.
А ще, застерігають критики, сплата біткоїнами значно ускладює пошук
тих, хто поширює і купує зброю, наркотики та інші нелегальні товари.